hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wie heute zu einem neuen video
hinterfragen die meisten gestellt wird
es luca wie bist du eigentlich verdammt
noch mal einen bescheuerten youtube
laden gekommen
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ich finde
heute ein komplettes video diesem thema
und woher meine begrüßung hallo mein
name ist luca kommt jaletzke
viele erwarten bei seinem thema halt
immer irgendein krasse geschichte von
wegen jo ich habe einen pakt mit dem
teufel abgeschlossen weil ich bei dem
unfall gestorben bin und nur damit ich
weiter auf der erde leben dürfte müsste
ich mir diesen youtube namen aneignet
oder so aber nee ist wirklich ganz
simpel eigentlich möchte freunde dass
ihr wenn ihr irgendwo kommentar unter
meinen videos sehen von wegen laufen so
heißt nicht konkreter dass ihr den
leuten einfach dieses video schickt das
dann das wird mir eine menge arbeit
abnehmen tatsächlich und lässt doch
vielleicht mal leid da wenn ihr denkt
ich ja ich kann euch keinen grund wieso
ich dieses video leiten sollte also wie
bin ich auf meinen namen gekommen mein
name ist ja con kräfte also geschrieben
cnc raf de erich kraft da kann sich
jeder denken woher das kommt aber ich
will euch einfach mal die komplette
entstehungsgeschichte des namens
erzählen ich habe vor meinem jetzigen
kanal namens kong crafter schon mal
einen anderen kanal namens konkreter lp
mich willst so interessiert auch noch
irgendwelche leute gerade abonnenten von
mir dieses video sehen die für
abonnenten von kontrolle wann bitte
schreibt man irgendwas die kommentare
dazu ich weiß jedoch soll etwa dass ich
dort so videos gemacht habe die auf zwei
in die richtung gaming gingen allerdings
nicht nur minecraft war also da war auch
minecraft dabei aber ich glaube auf sims
und irgendwie ballerspiele oder so ich
weiß lass' mich nicht lügen es wirklich
wenn jeder genaueres wird gerne einfach
mal die kommentare schreiben wird mich
selber auch interessieren jedenfalls
hatte ich diesen kanal dann halt so ein
halbes jahren ja irgendwie so um den
dreh und mir hat eigentlich immer schon
minecraft am meisten spaß gemacht und
das war auch das projekt was ich dort
hauptsächlich hochgeladen habe deswegen
hab ich mir gedacht okay
dieser kanal packt mich ab der name fand
mich ab es gab halt nicht so eine
möglichkeit von wegen nicht nennen main
kanal nahmen um sondern man hatte den
namen und dem musste man behalten und
dann dachte ich mir okay ich mache neuen
kanal ich habe jetzt erst irgendwie 1000
2000 abonnenten oder so hatte ich da das
war früher allerdings schon fast eine
menge und ich war halt schon immer ein
fan von fakt ist ich starte jetzt woran
er hingeschmissen ich war halt noch nie
mensch dafür der sagt okay ich würde das
gerne anders machen aber ich habe jetzt
schon so gemacht deswegen kann ich das
jetzt nicht mehr verändert deswegen euch
den kanal einfach geschlossen komplett
weg gemacht alle videos gelöscht ihr
findet den kanal auch nicht mehr also
wirklich braucht ihr gar nicht versuchen
also wirklich wenn ihr jetzt noch an die
zeit erinnert die kommentare voll mit
irgendwelchen story sachen nicht
hochgeladen habe vielleicht habe ich da
auch wenn euch geschrieben von mir zu
der zeit fällt immer alles voll weil
mich wird das übels interessiert das ist
so voll nostalgie gerade hier alles um
auf den punkt zu kommen ich hab das
neuen kanal gemacht den ich contractor
genannt habe und darum geht's ja jetzt
in diesem video nämlich wie bin ich auf
corporate wir müssen reddig bisschen
hier sowie bin ich auf kompakter
gekommen
wow ist eigentlich wirklich recht easy
also der damenkonkurrenz entstand
einfach daraus dass ich irgendwas
gesucht hat mit ware am ende weil das
waren früher so bei diesen ganzen
rollenspiel sachen diesmal alles immer
so gregor alkohol so ließ dann die
ganzen freunde von mir nehmen den
komischen jeffries spielen und ich sie
mal luca und dass wir sind scheint name
hab ich halt überlegt okay das könnte
ich für namen nehmen wo er hinten dran
gut passt deswegen habe ich dann
überlegt was mache ich denn zeit und in
dem moment wo ich überlegt habe ich das
spiel kommen dann kommt er kommt er
kommt irgendwie so jetzt das glaube ich
gespielt und dann habe ich gedacht okay
kommt am ende kommen man doch das war
irgendwie schon vergeben dann habe ich
ein kern genau aus dem spiel nahmen von
kommen den concorden machen die
sicherheit computer komplett blatt
da bleibt sich mit den neuen kanal
gemacht dann habe ich halt gedacht okay
konkret kraft oder sowas ist es viel zu
lange nämlich einfach das clever weg und
endlich kommen konnten war allerdings
auch schon vergeben dann habe ich
gedacht okay ich will auf dem kanal nur
minecraft hochladen dann packe ich
einfach kraft hinten dran allerdings war
konkret auch schon vergeben dann habe
ich mich an konnten kräfte genannt zu
der kraft da und das war dann halt frei
oder die sich halt konkreter und es gab
immer so von zeit zu zeit übels viele
theorien so kommen heißt noch mit
irgendwie auf spanisch oder so und dann
von wegen crafter mit crafter
zusammentraf das habe ich auch oft
gesagt wo ich keinen bock hatte diese
lange geschichte zu erzählen jargon
heißt mit kräfte als brav mit zusammen
kraft mit machen das zusammen das ist
die namen story aber eine freude dass
hier gerade das wirklich die real story
also bin ich auf den namen gekommen
witzig war halt auch viele leute haben
wir angeschrieben luca con heißt auf
französisch
und dann haben mich teilweise echt
eltern auch angesprochen sowie sohn
enste die spitzenkräfte
ich hatte auch früher so t shirt von
draufstand und dann habe ich leuten
gesagt wenn ihr damit von pedro geht und
wir in selb wichtig da seid ihr echt
heftig und danach mehrere leute so
bilder gemacht wie sie mit dem konzert
nach frankreich gefahren sind und sich
dann das wäre halt so wie wenn sich
jemand mit einem t shirt wird trotzdem
drauf steht vorm brandenburger tor
stellt das ganze allerdings wirklich
nicht meine absicht dabei hat sich mir
den namen überlegt habe sondern es war
ein baby so ich hatte mit früheren kanal
der quelle die hiscox warcraft bei mir
zum langen dann habe ich nur das korn
genommen freut mich komplett das war
nicht vergeben deswegen crafter ja das
ist quasi alle so bin ich einfach meinen
namen gekommen und dann hatte ich halt
eine relativ lange zeit immer so dieses
bedürfnis nach einer begrüßung weil
jeder youtuber irgendwie seine begrüßung
hatte dani hat sich irgendwas mit
bienchen leyen hat irgendwas mit löwen
bip hatte irgendwas mit
ich fahr rad fast um ich weiß gar nicht
genau was polizei hat allerdings beim
eine begrüßen dann irgendwann halt hallo
mein name ist luca geworden haben sich
auch wieder leute fragen zu helfen dass
luca einige leute hat man als ein
bisschen rum gehälter meinen dann ja
auch eine begrüßung ist von dem und dem
youtube angeblich geklaut allerdings
müssen wir wissen dass ich so etwas
ähnliches schon seit 2012 sagen das ist
mein facebook titelbild was ich am 29
januar 2012 erstellt habe und selbst das
sagt schon hallo ich bin luca und darauf
habe ich dann halt einen kanal banner
ausgerichtet und hab dann gedacht okay
das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute
begrüßung sage ich einfach hallo mein
name ist luca und daher kommt das und
nicht als irgendwie jeder macht
irgendwie was und ich kopiere das oder
so ich habe es eigentlich schon seit
anfang 2012
das ist quasi auch schon die story
hinter meinem namen contractor und
hintermänner begrüßung hallo mein name
ist luca bieler haben sich erste mal
gedacht dass der engel krasse story
hinter steckt aber es ist halt wirklich
einfach so mein name ist eine
zusammensetzung aus seinem alten namen
von mir und meinen körper ich dachte ich
werde nur minecraft auf meinem kanal
hochladen und hallo mein name ist luca
ist einfach eine umformung meines
facebook titelbildes aus dem jahre 2012
also das ist jetzt wirklich nichts
großartiges hier wenn euch dieses video
gefallen hat will ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen und schreit mir doch
mal die kommentare seit wann ihr
abonnenten zeit von meinem kanal bitte
jeder der jetzt gerade noch dran ist was
wahrscheinlich nicht viele sein werden
aber es dauert wirklich drei sekunden
kurz reinzuschreiben irgendwie januar
2016 oder februar 3014 oder november der
dreizehnte oder so ich fenster und rang
um zu wissen wie lange er schon beim
einen kanal mit dabei sein weil das ja
irgendwie teil von meinem leben ist und
irland teil meines lebens seit oder so
ich halte meine matches